welcome to other famous Friday I believe
that whatever goal you have whatever
obstacles are in your way somebody has
already solved it and instead of trying
to figure out everything for yourself
the fastest way to accomplish your goal
is to model the success of people who've
done it and apply their strategies to
your business so today's lesson is
invest in yourself from J Willard
Marriott who's the founder of the
Marriott hotel chain
now he's built an empire worth billions
but he came from very humble beginnings
he was the son of a poor sheep herder so
his dad herded sheep for a living and
all he knew was poverty growing up
around him all he knew was poverty and
just barely getting by as part of the
Mormon tradition J Willard had to go and
be a missionary and he left his home and
traveled across the United States being
a missionary for the Mormon tradition
and when he came back he found that his
father had lost his business that he ran
out of money the economy had collapsed
and his father and all the other sheep
herders were put out of business and he
was back to absolute poverty and this is
a really important time in J Willard's
life because up until that point he was
following his father's footsteps right
he learned about the Sheep he was set to
take over right raising the Sheep he
became a missionary just like his dad he
came home and he didn't want that life
anymore he didn't want to live in
poverty for the rest of his life and he
decided that the way to break free was
to invest him in himself he had to
invest in himself to gain the knowledge
to know what to do to gain the ideas to
break out of the situation that he was
in right now he decided I'm gonna go to
college there was one problem though he
didn't have money to go to college he
had nothing he was completely broke so
he went to talk to the president of the
college and he said I love to take the
courses I want to invest myself to break
out in my situation I'd like to trade
you if you give me tuition to let me
come into your school for free
I will teach your theology classes
which the only thing that he had
invested himself in before the only
thing that he knew the knowledge that
could benefit other people and he struck
that deal and the president said yes J
Willard was starting to rise at the
Community College he met his future wife
and he started his first business and
you may think of J Willard married as
the hotel chain Empire guy but he
started off in the food business he
started off selling soda drinks and he
started this business selling soda
drinks in the summer the problem was it
didn't great in the summer but then
failed in the winter because nobody
wanted to come and buy soda drinks in
the winter and all of the soda drink
companies a soda fountain come to the
set up were closing their doors in the
winter because nobody could get the
customers to come in and the business
started the change when his wife
realized that she had invested in
herself too and could leverage that to
help the business she had an interest in
cooking and she had gone to the Mexican
Embassy to learn how to cook Mexican
food and she said why don't we bring
food to this business so we're not just
selling soft drinks and she leveraged
their recipes and brought Mexican beef
sandwiches and tamale and and chili and
now this business started to take off
and they opened up multiple locations
soon they had another one and another
one and another one and they had eight
different locations then Mary got into
supplying food for the airline industry
and then from there he saw all those
travelers and said hey we should open up
some hotels and he created a
multi-billion dollar business but it all
started from nothing he had literally
nothing the poor son of a sheepherder
who had gone bankrupt and that was his
life that was what he was destined to
become and the change happened when he
stood up and decided to invest in
himself and when his wife decided to
invest in herself and apply that to
their business
that's the difference between being a
poor sheep herder and a billionaire
entrepreneur so if your stock you're not
seeing momentum
you're not seeing growth you think you
should be way up here but you're way
down here you have to invest in yourself
you have to learn the ideas the
knowledge the tools get access to the
resources in here and it could turn you
into a billion entrepreneur as well
believe if you guys like this video
subscribe to the channel see more just
like it thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon don't forget to click
here to subscribe to my newsletter to
get actionable inspiring motivational
believe advice every single week to your
inbox hi I'm Jason Grif on sigur rós
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period